So here's an example to explain why maybe
the situation's not so bad after all. So let's
look at a particular example. We've got our
input space consisting of say, the first 10 integers.
And our hypothesis space is, you take an
input, and then you just return whether it's greater
than or equal to some theta. So that's a
parameter. And now, how big is the hypothesis space?
>> What type is data?
>> Let's say theta's a real number.
>> Oh, so it's infinite. Infinite!
>> Indeed it is. Now, on the other hand, what
would you do to try to learn this? Can you use
the algorithm that we talked about before to learn in this
particular space? So, I guess what I'm asking is, is there
a way you can sort of sneakily apply the ideas
from before, now the ideas from before were that you actually
keep track of all the hypotheses. And to keep the version
space, and once you've seen enough examples that are randomly drawn,
you would be able to know that you've epsilon-exhausted the version
space, and then, ultimately, any hypothesis that's left is going to
be okay. So, what could we possibly do to track all
of these hypotheses? It's problematic, because
there's an infinite number of them.
>> Okay. I see where you're going with this. So when I
asked you what type it was, you said it was a real
number, but it would have been easier if it, theta weren't a
real number, but were in fact, you know, a positive integer say,
or a non-negative integer.
>> That's true, though there's still an infinite number of those.
>> True, but it doesn't matter because the size of
X is, it's so finite. So any value of theta
greater than ten for example It doesn't matter. It doesn't
matter because it will always give you the same answer.
>> Alright. So if we, what if we only track the
non-negative integers 10 or below. This would be, what, it's finite.
And it gives us the same answer, as if we had actually tracked the, the infinite
hypothesis space. So there's kind of, well, I
dunno, you had a, you had a good way
of saying it before, do you want to say
it again? What, what is the difference between
kind of this hypothesis space that we're working
with, and the hypothesis space as we defined it.
>> So there's a there's a notion of syntactic hypothesis space which is
all the things you could possibly
write, and then there's the semantic hypothesis
space which are the actual different
functions that you are practically represented.
>> Yeah, I like that, that, that you
can make a distinction between semantically, say, finite
hypothesis base and actually spec-, it specified syntactically
infinitely. And you also have the example of
of a decision tree. With discrete inputs as
also being kind of like this. That we,
you know, we, we generally think about only
ones that split on a attribute once, but syntactically
you could keep splitting on it. It just doesn't
give you a semantically different tree. So, this is
kind of at the heart of what we're going to
be able to do to talk about how we can
learn and if in an hypothesis space, more complicated
ones than this example here. But at the same time,
without having to track an infinite number of hypothesis,
because there's just not that many, that are meaningfully different.
>> I like that.